forschungsteams weltweit finden schon
seit jahren immer mehr beispiele dafür
dass wir tiere wohl lange gnadenlos
unterschätzt haben nicht nur menschen
darf man menschen können probleme lösen
individuelle entscheidungen treffen und
langfristig planen sondern auch einige
andere tierarten
das stellt die weltsicht der biologie so
komplett auf den kopf denn
offensichtlich haben wir uns selbst
lange zeit als spezielles überbewertet
welche experimente zeigen dass tiere
viel mehr sind als reine reiz reaktions
maschinen und wie sich forschungsteams
diese erkenntnisse beispielsweise beim
bau intelligenter maschine zu sitzen
machen wollen jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction das video sind
zusammenarbeit mit der richtig richtig
guten zeitschrift technology review
entstanden am ende habe ich ein
gratisexemplar für euch herzlich
willkommen
die große frage die über allem steht ist
das verhalten einer tierart das ergebnis
eines biologischen automatismus oder
aber steckt dort die planung
hartnäckigkeit ja vielleicht sogar die
individuelle entscheidungen eines tieres
dahinter immer mehr in diensten finden
forschungsteams weltweit jedenfalls
dafür dass wir die geistigen leistungen
anderer lebewesen sehr unterschätzt und
uns selbst total überschätzt haben dazu
ein beispiel ein französisches
forschungsteam konnte erst vor kurzem
zeigen dass honigbienen nicht nur in der
lage sind kleine mengen zu vergleichen
sondern dass die tiere sogar das konzept
der zahlen 0 verstehen in dem experiment
wurden die bienen mit zuckerlösung
belohnt wenn sie das bild auswählten
dass die wenigste ansatz als elementen
zeigte
wenn die tiere also zwischen einem bild
mit drei oder sechs elementen wählen
konnten sollten sie im besten fall dass
mit den drei elementen
das forschungsteam war mehr als
überrascht als sie bienen sich für das
bild ohne punkte also für 0-elemente
entschieden es scheint also so als
wüssten die bienen das 0 auch eine zahl
ist kinder brauchen jahre um das zu
verstehen denn die null ist neurologisch
gesehen eine riesige herausforderung
dazu adrian meyer von der university
melbourne der an dem experiment
beteiligt war
es ist relativ einfach für neuronen auf
reize wie licht oder die anwesenheit
eines objektes zu reagieren
aber wie können wir oder sogar einen
sekt verstehen was nichts ist wie kann
ein gehirn nichts darstellen dass auch
bienen also insekten dafür die nötige
intelligenz haben ist neu etwas länger
wissen wir schon dass auch vögel und
affen dazu in der lage sind aber dass
insekten das können also das zeigen auch
experimente mit hummeln die an eine
versteckte blüte gelangen sollten und
gab erlernten an einem faden zu ziehen
doch woher kommt dieses intelligente
verhalten hat es viel weniger mit
höheren hirnfunktionen zu tun als wir
bislang vermutet haben ein unfassbar
spannender aspekt für die entwicklung
künstlicher intelligenz den roboter
beispielsweise sollen sich ja in äußerst
komplexen umgebungen zurechtfinden dazu
da eine straße zu überqueren ist für
erwachsenen menschen einfach wir
verstehen wenn es keine autos fahrräder
oder straßenbahn gehen aber was ist null
wie stellen wir dies für so viele
komplexe objekt lassen darf um
entscheidungen in komplexen umgebungen
zu treffen
wenn bienen 0 mit einem gehirn von
weniger als einer million euro
wahrnehmen können deutet das darauf hin
dass es einfache effiziente wege gibt ki
neue tricks beizubringen einige forscher
und forscherinnen glauben auch an die so
genannte intelligenz ohne repräsentation
ein verhalten das auf einer direkten
aber dennoch nicht rein automatischen
verarbeitung von informationen
resultiert ohne dass lebewesen dazu ein
abstraktes konzept verstehen müssten
einige forschungsteams nehmen in diesem
zusammenhang beispielsweise an das
spinnennetze ein teil des kognitiven
systems der tiere sind und die netze um
so straffer sein jäger die tiere seien
der fang von beute wird damit
wahrscheinlich
dazu ein verfechter dieser theorie der
australische biologen schenk kognition
ist von zentraler bedeutung für die
intelligenz kommt aber in mehr
variationen vor als die üblichen theorie
besagt für viele verhalten forscher und
forscherinnen steht jedenfalls fest
sowie die klassische biologie die welt
mit ihren hierarchien beschreibt ist sie
so nicht mehr gültig denn demnach soll
die intelligenz eines tieres umso
kleiner sein
je weiter es vom stammbaum des menschen
entfernt ist so müssten also schafe
klüger sein als vögel denn diese sind
keine säugetiere
es gibt allerdings nicht weniger
experimente die das gegenteil beweisen
krähen vögel zum beispiel sind nicht nur
in der lage sich selbst im spiegel zu
erkennen und werkzeuge zu nutzen
sie können auch langfristig planen dazu
jonas rose von der ruhr-uni bochum von
herrn weiß man dass sie futter für die
zukunft verstecken wenn es in einen
käfig zum beispiel zum frühstück immer
mehlwürmer gibt in dem anderen immer
erdnüsse und man den eichelhäher am
abend vorher erdnüsse und mehlwürmer
anbietet verstecken sie genau das futter
dass es in diesem käfig am nächsten
morgen nicht geben wird
in experimenten konnten sie mit hilfe
von mikroelektroden im gehirn der tiere
zeigen dass das arbeitsgedächtnis der
vögel mit dem von affen vergleichbar ist
zudem hat das forschungsteam weitere
studien in arbeit die ein weiteres
überraschendes ergebnis haben demnach
denken vögel auf dieselbe art und weise
wie tiere mit einer gehirnrinde also nur
mit weniger ressourcen dabei verfügen
vögel überhaupt nicht über diese schicht
des gehirns auch tauben sind cleverer
als die meisten von uns wohl glauben sie
können sinnvolle wörter von sinnfreien
buchstabenkombinationen unterscheiden
und diese tricks müssen die tiere wohl
nicht einmal lernen entenküken erklären
das erste lebewesen dass sie in ihrem
enden leben sehen als ihre mutter egal
ob es eine entenmama ist oder aber
gegenstände oxford so logan
prägten so entenküken auf zwei blaue
kugeln die an den enden verwaltungen
danach entschieden sich die küken für
die identischen formen selbst wenn sie
kugeln mit verschiedenen farben und
gegenständen mit derselben form aber mit
fremden farben zur auswahl hatten
doch das macht eine äußerst wichtige
sache in diesem zusammenhang klar
dazu martin trostel einer der oxford
forscher wir wollten zeigen dass jedes
system das beliebige gegenstände
identifizieren kann auch dazu in der
lage ist abstrakte kategorien zu lernen
das bedeutet nicht dass die enten ein
abstraktes konzept gelernt haben alles
was wir sagen können ist dass sie sich
so verhalten als ob sie ein abstraktes
konzept gelang captain heißt also auf
vorsicht vor überinterpretation in
tierexperimenten sollte man nicht
vorschnell menschenähnliche intelligenz
in einem verhalten reinlesen doch warum
haben säugetiere dann so viele
nervenzellen wenn tiere mit weniger
nervenzellen ähnlich intelligentes
verhalten zeigen können die erklärung
dafür die ergebnisse scheinen ähnlich zu
sein doch für spezielle leistungen in
bestimmten lebensverhältnissen braucht
es wohl doch mehr neuronen das
nervensystem der tiere produziert
jederzeit mögliche verhaltensweisen mit
vielen neuronen generiertes jedoch auch
besonders viele verhaltens möglichkeiten
um dann durch versuch und irrtum eine
lösung zu finden intelligenz also als
eine art modulbaukasten mit
verschiedenen geistigen fähigkeiten
das sieht auch born brems von der
universität regensburg so menschliche
intelligenz ist einzigartig einzigartig
in dem sinne in dem auch die morphologie
eines nagetiers einzigartig ist heißt
also die eben genannten beispiele sind
gar nicht so faszinierend weil sie
zeigen wie intelligent vögel oder bieten
wirklich sind sondern weil sie zeigen
wenig neuronaler rechenpower spezielle
geistige leistungen möglich sind für
intelligentes verhalten in maschinen
hieße das dann für höhere kognitive
fähigkeiten ist kein großes weit
entwickeltes gehirn notwendig
intelligentes verhalten ließe sich sogar
in ein kleines roboter hirn einpflanzen
ein superrechner ist demnach nicht mehr
notwendig und so kommen neuen
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
und computerwissenschaftler
wissenschaftlerinnen zusammen um ihre
disziplin zu vereinen
das unternehmen gibt meint hat ein
neuronales netz entwickelt das erfahrung
für allgemein hat es probiert wahllos
aktionen aus um ein problem zu lösen
erfolgreiche aktionen der software
werden belohnt und sie wird dadurch
immer besser
einer der entwicklermesse botton wink
sieht dieses metall learning als
wesentliche schlüssel zur künstlichen
allgemeinen intelligenz denn unsere welt
besitzt eine spezifische eigenart wir
erleben niemals dieselbe situation
zweimal aber wir erleben auch niemals
eine komplett neue situation jedes
intelligente system muss also die
fähigkeit besitzen die erfahrungen der
vergangenheit zu nutzen um sie auf
elegante und schnelle weise auf neue
aufgaben zu übertragen
als großes ziel der ki forschung sieht
er die entwicklung einer umgebung in der
die kühlsysteme leben lernen und
trainieren können den umgekehrten weg
geht ein forschungsteam aus deutschland
aus dem echten leben rein in einen daran
angelehntes computerprogramm hier wurden
modelle gebaut die an die sogenannten
pilzkörper von bienen angelehnt waren
dort wo die neuronalen netzwerke bei den
bienen zusammenlaufen hier wurde nur
festgelegt ob und wenn ja wie stark zwei
nervenzellen miteinander verbunden sind
dazu einer der forscher laschet gab dann
haben wir ausprobiert was passiert wenn
man informationen durch diese netze
pumpt sie also gewissermaßen
verschiedenen umwelt die molli aussetzt
22 juli wurden zunächst trainiert einer
positiv nämlich an blumenduft der vielen
tollen bringt und ein duft der sich am
ende nicht wirklich lohnt dem
entwickelten netz wurden dann neue aber
ähnliche dürfte vorgesetzt und
tatsächlich wie
vielen hirn simulationen bevorzugte
einen duft der in dem belohnten geruch
am ähnlichsten war und der gleichzeitig
maximal weit weg von den bestraften lag
so wurde also der gesamtnutzen optimiert
was die forscher auch als das pik
schiffs verhalten bezeichnen das fazit
das experiment ist erstaunlich und soll
so auf viele weitere
kg übertragen werden damit diese auf
einer art intelligent werden wie sich
die meisten von uns heutzutage nicht
mehr im traum vorstellen können dazu der
zoologe mattino trasse wir sind umgeben
von unglaublich vielen gehirn die in der
lage sind aufgaben zu lösen die wir gern
von maschinen lösen lassen wird er nennt
das beispiel der ameisen und wer weiß
vielleicht sind ja autonom fahrende
autos da schon bald so intelligent wie
ameisen
ok vielen dank an die redaktion von
technology review
die dieses mind blowing thema für uns
recherchiert hat hier bekommt ihr
einfach draufklicken ein gratis heft
unter drunter geht's weiter mit einem
anderen thema von technology review
was soll das erstes schwimmendes
atomkraftwerk bis dann bleibt dran